No, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no.
No.
She's freaking it.
I'm always freaking it.
Oh my
god!
Don't add me to your friends list!
It was a notification of people trying to add me to a
friends list!
Get out of here!
My voice is really bad today.
Oh my goodness.
Get out of here!
Stop!
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god.
She's down with the sickness.
Actually, no!
I'm...
Oh my god.
Of course if I say something.
You guys will all be there.
freaking about it.
But no!
Well, I was gonna say I'm all better.
But I'm not all better.
I still have a cough.
Jason, welcome membership.
The Japanese...
With what?
Brain rot is real.
Minto, minto, minto, minto, minto, minto, minto, minto,
minto, minto, minto, minto, minto, It doesn't really roll
off the tongue very well though.
Welcome to Tetrio!
It's been a long time since I've played this before.
It's been a really, really, really, really, really, really
long time.
So, still don't understand the deer meme?
What is there to understand?
It's just a catchy song.
That's all.
Hello, made Minto, Minto, Minto, Minto Minto Phantom.
Thank you.
We wisps take after you.
We have no choice but to be freaky.
And clowny, apparently.
Yeah, it's just an earworm from an anime.
Hmm.
What round did you get to, Emblems?
Uh, I think it was 165.
I think it's 165.
up.
Mint is good at Tetrio?
Of course I am.
She's a world champion.
I'm of the digital world.
I'm the digital world champion.
Change into digital monsters to is save the digital world.
But yeah.
Move aside.
Firestorm.
Minton Town now.
I don't even know who that is.
I think.
That's how insignificant they are to me.
I don't know.
hmm yeah I just figured it's a Friday it's a Friday night
and I haven't played this in literally years with you guys
sorry Minto lovers but you just made that account now Minto
lover the one hour dear song has given me a migraine well
What the?
You can message me even?
Get out of here!
It's given you...
I don't think you should listen to it for an actual
migraine, maybe.
You know?
I think, like, it's not meant for that.
How are you guys doing this?
You're not my friends!
Hi!
Wait, what?
There's a streamer mode?
Oh, okay, I'm going to streamer mode.
Hold on, let me hide my screen.
Hold on.
Where is it, under?
Um, I just have to find it.
Um.
I'm going to turn off notifications real quick, also.
Let's see.
Um.
Uh, oh, I cannot turn them.
off.
Really?
Oh wait, here we go.
Notify me.
Off, off, off, off, off, off, off.
Off, off, off.
Is there a streamer mode?
Filter profanity.
No cousin in my chat.
dear friend.
Oh, what was that?
Someone gave me one month of Tetrio supporter!
Stop it!
Freaking cussing!
You freaking freaks!
Anytime that I would get mad at Mataro while we were
together.
Anytime I would get mad at her, she would be like, you
freaking freaks!
That's what you sound like.
You freaking freaks!
That's That's what you sound like right now, Mint.
She would do that every time.
When will you learn?
The directions have consequences!
I don't think there is a streamer mode.
Unless I'm blind.
Which is...
I mean, it might be these glasses, to be honest.
It's my favorite YouTube video.
It's a classic, truly.
I've been wanting to catch them in stream.
Glad to have them made it.
Welcome!
What's with the shades?
I just thought they were cool.
You're blocking the messages now, so maybe it's okay.
Maybe now.
Yeah, maybe.
Okay.
Yeah, I'm cool.
I'm cool now.
But I'm still getting notifications when somebody asks me.
Two months, baby!
Yurie!
Wait, under account, you can edit your privacy settings.
Oh, I can.
Okay, thank you.
Hold on.
Sorry.
I didn't know it'd be like this.
Wait.
Under accounts, a privacy set.
Where?
Wait.
Oh, change account settings.
Okay, hold on.
Hold on, hold on.
Write a little something about me.
Who can add me as a friend?
My friends can only add me as a friend.
Oh wait Oh no, I think I have to do this I think I have to
do Everybody can see what room I'm in So that we can all
play together Who can send me direct messages?
Nobody, nobody, nobody Okay There we go Quit talking to me
What the?
Still adding me, though.
Wait, streamer mode is...
It's under configuration desktop.
Desktop?
I don't say it.
Hmm.
Desktop.
Oh, it's for desktop version, not browser.
Oh, okay.
Okay, anyway.
This should be fine now, I think.
Let's say, I'm gonna do a little bit of a warm-up.
I'm gonna do a bit of a warm-up.
Don't be shocked by my Zen level, okay?
Or anything like that.
I also made this account today.
I made this account today.
So, um...
Do 40 lines.
No, we're gonna, um...
Uh...
Yeah, I had to make a Smurf account.
Mint deleted her old account.
I did!
I actually tried to log in, back into it, and it was like,
this account is deleted.
So I had to make a whole new one, baby.
Which I was really happy this wasn't, um, taking my name.
Yeah, so, you know...
I deleted my old account.
I nuked it.
Yeah, I was... it's gone.
I scrubbed it from the internet.
So nobody could ever, ever see.
A fresh start.
Anyway.
Chat summary is wild.
What is mint Zen mode?
Why it... Does it like...
Does it...
Does it take what I say or only what the chat says?
Anyway, um, if you're gonna come in here and be a big old
jerk to me, um...
You can go be a jerk in someone else's chat.
That's all I'm gonna say.
Look at that!
Wait, oh shoot, uh, wait.
Oh, there we go.
Okay.
And then...
Nope.
Oh, shoot.
Oh.
It's space.
Wow, this bass riff just kind of...
And then shift.
You guys can't be adding me around practicing, okay?
You guys...
Chill out, okay?
I was... I was... I took the screenshot earlier of my...
of my...
thumbnail.
Should I like my thumbnail?
Do you guys like that?
Pretty nifty, eh?
Yeah.
Tetris is fun.
Tetris is a bit stressful for me.
But I do enjoy it.
I mostly enjoy just being able to play games with you guys.
So even if I'm bad at something, I just choose it because
I'm like, well, I at least have something to play with
people.
So to me, it doesn't really matter if I'm good or bad.
I'm just kind of vibing.
And we can all vibe together on this lovely Friday.
You know?
I didn't trust myself to keep building that.
Wow!
Murphy!
My day is pay.
And my Yoshi is cute.
You know it.
Thank you for that.
Why did you send that?
See my happy birthday!
Sing me...
Hold on.
Here, I'm just...
I'm practicing real quick.
Give me a second.
Give me, like, one minute.
Square blog.
Oh.
There we go.
Good.
This is pretty clean, though.
Isn't it what she said?
I remember one advice someone gave me a long time in the go
in the past.
They were like, this one, these Z blocks, don't put them
vertical if you can help it.
Is that still a true statement?
Yes or no.
Discuss.
Like that.
Don't put it like that.
Build flat.
No, I think the meta changed.
Oh!
That's- this is all I know!
No way!
Don't destroy chat.
You know, I'm- this is a glorified Zatudan stream.
So...
Okay, I think I've practiced enough.
I think I've practiced enough.
Let's see.
Where'd you go?
DUI.
Boss, you think of us as people.
Sorry.
I didn't mean to say that.
I didn't mean to let that slip.
Could you please favor me with the terrifying lows, the
dizzying highs, and the creamy middles of one of your famous
birthday greetings?
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear dear wife.
Happy birthday to you!
My voice is cracking a lot today.
I
don't remember how to do this.
Multiplayer.
I think I create a room, right?
Play by my rules!
So if I create a public room...
Oh, made mince room!
Oh!
Passam!
Oh,
so...
Super Lobby!
I think I've only ever had that once before!
What is this lobby?
Uh-oh, I think there's people gotta come in that don't know
who I am.
Uh-oh.
Um...
And it keeps going!
I can hear it very faintly.
If you win, you get a permanent badge to show you one in a
room with 100 plus people.
Try to win.
I want that!
This is a good thing.
No context mint is the best.
Look up, made mint on YouTube channel!
200 people keeps going
hello mid mid why are they calling me out
you are so pro vtuber wait i'm scared who are these people
if you are unsure how Wow, we have 100 players, it's a
lobby, you have a survival...
Wait, why are there people like in here being like...
There's people in here being like, this is why there's so
many people playing.
I don't know, is there a limit in this room?
Is there a limit?
We're just gonna let everybody in who wants to join.
Hey, don't quit.
I saw I went down to 240.
800.
Oh yeah!
The real limit is the server's going down.
Oh!
I hope people don't come in expecting... They're gonna see
me wearing my freak phantom glasses.
Honestly, probably the best, um, the best introduction.
Look, I'm level two!
I'm level two!
There's people literally level like 3,000 here.
Oh, gosh.
We even have Yukari Yakumo of Toho Fam.
The freak phantom glasses are the perfect introduction.
I think so, too.
Need to be level 3 before you can chat.
Really?
I test.
You're right!
I can't even chat in my own room!
Stop laughing in both chats.
This is so cursed.
Free her mods!
Give me a special privileges!
I think we're done though.
What is plus three?
Is that mean spectators?
Okay.
Well, I guess we'll start um got it uh oh player limit auto
start public room no you can't be anonymous and join you
have to be you have to be a you have to be someone you have
to be willing to share your stuff we're not hiding likes
here and for the record i always kept my likes up open i
always liked what i wanted to See it or not!
Wait for 300?
Okay.
We'll wait for 300.
Oh, they're crying.
Even butt wiping?
I don't think I ever liked anything about that.
Did anybody ever even look though?
I never even thought about it.
I never thought that people would look at my likes.
so maybe that's why i just didn't care we did look really
let let a non's in any way there's no real danger no i just
want to it's not that it's a danger thing i just want to see
people's names i want to know what to call them okie dokie
save and let's start at 307 players
I'm scared!
Minto, the hero, would have kept the likes tab.
Wait, how do I do this again?
Okay.
Oh my gosh, I forgot how much I...
Oh, no, not caps off this.
I forgot how much I like the music in this game.
Um, shoot.
Oh.
Oh gosh, you guys.
I'm nervous!
I'm so scared right now.
I'm...
I'm really nervous right now.
Oh my God.
Whoa!
It's all like, ah!
It's all coming in.
It's all coming in too fast.
Hold on, don't, don't, don't shoot anything at Minto,
please.
I haven't played this game in like so many years, okay?
My granny brain's gotta keep up.
My granny, oh shoot, why did I do that even?
Oh shoot, but screw it up.
Oh, this one.
Guys, am I gonna make it?
Be honest.
Are we gonna make it, chat?
Chat, are we gonna make it?
Something, something, chat, is this real?
I don't remember how to teaspoon.
I learned maybe, like, once.
I learned once, and then...
Never again did I remember.
Yesent.
Okay.
What rank do you think will get?
Oh, what's that sound?
Sounds like little ants running around.
What is that?
Is it my headphones?
What is that sound?
Eek!
Eekam, eekam!
Eekam, bokam!
Oh.
Oh, wait!
Oh my god, I escaped.
Oh, no, I did not.
I think we're donezo, maybe a little bit.
Oh shoot.
Oh.
Oh sh- 100 players left!
I'm doing it!
Oh!
Trusted!
What did I get?
I don't want to see this...
eventual ghost!
Oh my god, it's a bloodbath out here.
Can't believe I ranked lower than men.
Really?
You can't believe that?
Who else is in here?
Who's this?
Potatoes!
Oh, we can zet- wait.
How do I see what my rank was, though?
That's what I'm trying to look for, sorry.
Mint is too pro.
I know.
This person's even- their name is killed.
They come in with hostile intentions.
They come in with too hostile of intentions.
Get his ass!
Wipe his pipe!
Wipe it!
Wipe
it!
Fast Boba living up to their name.
The games you would think with 300 people they would go by
like really slowly.
But no...
Oh!
Cheater!
You're cheating!
Oh my god he's gonna get his ass wiped!
Get wiped.
Oh my gosh, we're already down to two.
Before I can even finish my sentence, grapevine!
Oh my god, wait.
No way.
I feel
like I recognize this name.
I feel like it.
Who else would get 69?
Nice.
With these freaky glasses on.
Wait, who got next to me?
Hello.
Don't sniff her.
Get out of here.
Sniffer.
Okay, bye!
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
I got the funny number.
That's so silly.
GG grape.
I don't want to eat grapes anymore.
What are you talking about?
I love grapes!
What is this one, one, one?
oh one one out of one oh they won oh bye grape see ya all
right let's try again ready dang dang dang 328 holy cow god
Guys, this is a chill game, okay?
This is a chill game.
We're just chilling.
We're vibing, okay?
Just take it easy, everybody.
Take it easy.
Take it.
Oh, wait, I forgot.
I thought I had something different.
That's fine.
Oh.
There we go.
Just, everybody, chill out.
Let's all just go nice and slow.
Why is the music so epic?
No!
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, whoa.
Oh my god.
They're already really coming for my head.
I got 69th and they're like, you're a threat.
We won't let you get ahead any longer.
That was your highest score today, Minto.
Is what the boss music is saying.
I'm scared.
I'm really scared right now.
I'm worried about my complexion.
Oh gosh.
Oh.
Oh, there we go.
Build flat.
But it's really hard.
Oh.
Ugh.
Okay.
Oh, flat is just...
Oh.
I already messed up.
Just get it out of here.
I'm building flat.
And nicely.
And evenly.
Look at that.
Why is this like JoJo ass music?
What's going on?
No!
Don't touch me.
Oh, hey, hey, hey, hey!
Ah!
Wait, what?
What did I die at, everybody?
What did I die
at, everybody?
What did you take me for?
102.
No.
This is literal hell.
This is what the final boss music is for.
Look at him.
He's building up his own teeth.
He's making two of them.
Oh my god.
Literally crying.
Wipe his ass!
He's gonna make it, he's gonna make it out alive.
Why are you crying?
Because I'm so moved.
What did you be?
I'm sorry.
Sorry.
We're watching it.
artist at work it's true oh my god I can't stop crying oh
this
is peak wait he died oh my god wait when did that happen oh
but you were supposed to you killed me you can't kill me and
then not win
game I made top 100
unrelated but in the new Dragon Ball Sparking Zero game one
of the lines Goku says when you go in Super Saiyan is kept
you waiting huh?
I saw that I did see that the new game looks awesome
Didn't expect Castlevania music in a vlog.
I got 69.
Really?
I'll be the judge.
Oh, you really did.
But next to Baby Buttgeeks.
My birthday ended days ago, but it's never too late.
Guys, I love!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear Gonzalo!
Happy birthday.
Wow, who got last?
Oh, I think these people dissed?
Gummy crow.
You got last.
Like it.
I can chat now with Kandai.
Hello.
I'm getting that badge.
Me too.
Wow, thank you.
You're here playing Tetra with yourself by and work has been
slow, so I'm slipping in some games in between.
but i'm enjoying your vibes so have a sub and a don't know
what no way thank you thank you so much i appreciate it good
luck with work no you can use a controller here oh my gosh
we have people doing the rolling method you know where they
hold it and then they go with their fingers no way may admit
you're going down i'm already down don't put me any further.
Grape is back.
Oh my gosh, I remember this.
Okay, grape.
Let's see what you can do.
Can you get...
Wait, so do you get a badge if you just win a game?
Or do you have to win the entire room?
uh that'd be crazy
osk is in the lobby he's the founder of of tetrio oh no
what's happening here i hear that whenever osk is in the
room with you crazy things may happen brace yourself hi hi
i'm gonna start No!
I'm scared!
Ah!
Beep!
Go!
Faster!
We must be faster, we must be faster!
This music is killing my vibe though.
This music is killing my vibe!
OSK, I demand you take it out the set list.
Remove it!
If you can hear me!
I don't... I can't...
Oh no, oh no, no.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, no, I don't mean it.
Ah, I didn't mean it, please!
Please, please, please.
It's...
Ah!
Oh, God.
It's...
God, if there is...
Oh!
I was gonna say, if there is a John Tetris out there,
please.
Let me live.
It's okay.
Oh, we're back to Grape.
The Mint Superfan 9000 got KO.
Look at them.
They're just dropping like flies.
Grape is taking out everybody.
I died instantly.
It's okay me too because I was too busy laughing.
It's the song, everybody.
It's the song.
soundtrack choice will you
laughing is is game interference and coffee killed what are
you talking about oh my god grape you're only ranked your
only placement 62 one come on get better man get better oh
oh okay
Almost three pieces per second.
That's insanity.
Did you mess out?
No, he didn't.
Of course not.
Grape Nied win.
Yeah, for real.
Wait.
Oh my god, you can do that?
No,
Binti Fresh!
Like I said, guys, I'm not good at Tetris.
But it's all about...
It's all about not taking yourself seriously and just having
a good time, you know?
This is the... What's the guy in here?
Oh, Baby Island!
Wow, they're actually like getting better, so like the games
are longer now.
You know?
Usually it's like it was down to like...
Oh!
Were you teasing eyes?
You little tease.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
Whoa, whoa, oh, oh, it's getting really serious!
Whoa, it's getting hot!
Oh, boom, Tetris hurt Brae SkidB Island!
Oh, ow!
Oh my god.
Oh, wow!
Boom Tetris!
Oh, die, oh!
They are so sweaty.
Sushi man's going crazy.
Everybody here.
That was the sound, by the way, guys.
Oh!
Why?
I think PP Island's got him on speed.
Yeah.
Oh, maybe.
Oh!
And game!
Sound is good?
Okay, thank you.
E-Kenzy.
Mm-hmm.
253.
It was the vibes of the song.
Okay.
Who is next to me?
Anybody?
Anybody next to Minto?
Oh, wait.
I'm up here.
Jocko.
Paper bags.
Nice.
I locked in the 34th.
No way.
You're pulling my leg.
You're there.
Shouse.
289 don't look no one day we need to make anybody below 100
we need to if you you can't join unless you're below 100 in
um in in in rank oh man if you want i could set the game
mode to battle royale under the match tab it's a bit more
beginner friendly Oh, thank you!
I could set the game mode to battle royale.
Do we want to try that?
I don't mind it being not beginner friendly, but...
Yeah, you know what?
We do have a big lobby, so let's try doing that.
Yeah.
Thank you, always gay!
Let me see.
Just in case you...
Thank you!
Yeah, let's try it.
Oh, that's so nice.
Don't forget to save.
Oh, thank you.
save room configuration updated so now it's us it's it's uh
like room v room right wait first two come on around wait
wait how does this work actually wait wait where we drop
them in do four by 100 no one wait
Just leave it as is?
Let's start it.
Let's see how it goes.
Let's see what happens.
Why is the real number keep going up?
The BGLH.
Oh, this is so cute.
See, this is the chill.
You know, everybody?
We were talking about.
Tetris is no big deal.
Yo, everyone.
Tetris is no big deal, yo.
Be fast.
I gotta be faster.
And I gotta not second guess my...
My...
Okay, build.
I need to not just take down.
I need to build.
Oh, that's fine.
That's fine.
Build, build.
Build, build, build, build.
Build, build, build.
Oh, build.
It's so sad!
Build, build, build, build, build, build, build, build,
build, build, build, build buildings.
Destroy!
I don't know why I just took out.
Probably some sad sap.
Didn't even know what was gonna hit him.
But boom, coming with the made minto.
Parfait.
Oh,
oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, what was that?
Don't target me.
I'm the streamer.
Oh, ow.
Oh my gosh, don't target me, I'm the streamer!
Please!
Oh, shoot.
Uh.
I'm okay, everybody, I'm fine.
Maybe.
Maybe I'm okay.
Gosh, this is forcing me to really get good, isn't it?
Okay.
Yes, sir!
Yes, sir.
No, sir.
Oh, no, sir!
No, sir, no, sir, no, sir!
No, sir!
Uh-oh.
Oh.
No, no, sir.
Oh, no, sir.
Oh, shoot.
Shoot, shoot, sir!
Oh, sir, sir.
Oh, I'm sorry, sir.
I'm sorry, sir.
Ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah!
Ah, ah, ah, ah,
ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
No, yes, sir I live sir I live sir.
I live sir!
How did I make it out?
Oh shoot.
I think I you guys I think I've um, I think I said music is
Really killing me I threw
for real
Top 100, though.
Yippee!
I'm really sweaty.
Got to love your freestyle, Rappa.
I was in rollercoaster of emotions.
Was my Yoshi Pippi Island in this?
Old man, Yao-y.
Oh, oh, it's came right there.
I see PP.
There's fast Boba.
Woohoo!
Lo!
Funny coincidence, I arrived back home from Japan, same day
of your return stream.
Sadly, no main cafe, but I love eating at the Kirby cafe!
Woo!
Nice!
How many people?
367?
I think?
Speedifier, welcome back!
The game just gets too fast.
Uh-oh.
Oh, you can fix this.
The way your mood changes, playing Tetris is like watching
the I'm a genius.
Oh, no, me one.
What's that meme?
Back to lurking.
Thank you.
The L-turns are always- I know, right?
That's the things that I don't expect.
The L-turns!
They're really crazy.
Can you do that in normal Tetris?
Or like...
Because I've never...
I mean, I don't watch so much Tetris stuff, but...
Mostly T.
Okay.
You can do it in modern Tetris now.
Wow!
No, I know T spins.
turns though, aren't real.
T-spins.
Okay, I know the T-spins are real, yeah.
In Tetris 99, you can.
In NES Tetris, no.
Na-doh-doh, na-doh-doh.
T-spins aren't real, I can't hurt you.
Hell no, this isn't me playing.
I wouldn't be able to talk and play like this?
So delicate.
Minito is so good.
I thought you were being really cool.
Play like this without talking?
Probably.
I could probably play I could probably play 50 times better
than this guy without talking.
And also I'm also off stream.
I can play 50 times better than this guy off stream.
Streamer debuff.
Yeah, I get a little bit of anxiety.
The, you know, you guys watching just really makes me
anxious and nervous and sweaty.
If she wasn't streaming, she'd be number one tech true.
That's true!
Pikachu, welcome to membership!
Thank you!
Ten people left!
Oh, PPI Island!
Oh, oh, oh, PPI- oh!
They're throwing on purpose because he told them to.
What?
He fought himself!
Zeus!
Aresus!
I leveled up.
I want to say that you're awesome.
Thank you, my sister!
I got 88th though.
that's not so bad I thought I was just top 100 but I got
88th I mean I am top 100 but like nice I'll take it
especially because I got taken down by the freaking winner
you freaking freaksa that 300 plus that's good yeah it's not
bad right yippee I don't understand this game mode though I
don't really understand it.
There was some D-Sync.
Fig Jam!
Thanks for the five gifted.
Thank you.
I didn't KO OSK.
So sad.
Seems like Tetris 99 maybe.
Royal basically works the same as Tetris 99, but without the
garbage cap.
Ah, okay, okay.
Well, cool.
Oh my gosh, we're almost a 400 people in here.
This is wild!
Cosmic down!
Thanks for the five gifted!
Holy cow!
Alright.
Message about now.
Huh?
About who, huh?
What, what?
About now.
Hello?
Huh?
Okay, anyway.
Okay, let's start the game.
378.
Holy moly.
I die!
Beep.
Ooh, mysterious.
I could do a T-spin right there.
Okay, I have to handle myself appropriately.
Hold on, I'm setting up!
Gosh!
Wait.
Oh, I messed it up.
Never mind!
Hold on, please!
Please!
No!
God!
Let me fix this, okay?
Hold on, I just wanted to...
I wanted to be like the cool kids, man!
This is torture!
Oh, oh, okay.
Oh, no.
Like this...
I think I'm in trouble.
Guys, I think I'm in trouble.
I didn't even get to play!
I tried.
There was an attempt.
Lying too close to the sun on that one.
Maybe this isn't the best place to, to, to, um...
To, you know, practice.
Maybe Battle Royale isn't better for noobs.
OSK really just under, totally overestimated my skill level
up in here.
It's okay, though.
This is how you get better by playing against the real good
people.
It's true, though.
It's my fault.
played in literal years, so.
It's all my fault.
Who else is in here?
Oh!
You got this, Durban!
How do you even see with those shades?
I'm telling you.
With my instincts.
They're not very sharp, though.
One for Tetris Effects Connected on Steam.
Oh.
Tetris Effects... Is that the one, though, chill one that,
like, takes you through time and space.
No, that's...
Wait.
No, that is the Tetris effect, isn't it?
Isn't it that Tetris effect?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
About for Puyo Puyo.
I am so garbage at Puyo Puyo, though.
If you want to see even more pain than this today.
Tetris effect that moves with Ashton Kutcher.
You can play Tetris Effect in VR!
I remember, like, like, you go through the ocean and
there's, like, space... space...
What's the word?
Space whales.
I like Tetris with Carcaptur, Sakurapur, and then like...
Wow!
Fix it!
Gives me such a throwback to be able to play with you in
chat since last time many years ago.
Here's my first Aqua Supa since I wasn't able back then.
Thank you!
I really appreciate it.
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
I know it is a bit of a throwback though, isn't it?
Not even a bit of a throwback, like a lot of a throwback.
Is Minta Pro at Honey Pop?
Oh yeah.
Don't you know it?
Dang, Dave is really holding his own up in here.
I saw you play detective games.
I think you'd like Tangle Tower on Steam.
It's a murder mystery.
Ooh, thanks for the suggestion.
It's
okay, he can recover.
That wasn't your fault.
I've never felt so inadequate as a gamer.
Honey Pop Stream win.
When I decide that I no longer need this channel, I guess.
I think YouTube would ban me, wouldn't they?
Even, there's like a save for work version, though, isn't
there?
But I still think that I would.
I think like even on Twitch, even if you play the save for
work one.
You can play it patched on YouTube?
No, uh, really?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, sushi man.
She's still in her.
Remilia!
That's my Oshi right there.
Wait, Remilia?
Remilia?
Oh, Remilia, where'd you go?
Yeah, these people are crazy good.
Sushi Man said nope.
Whoa!
And then the game said nope.
Back at him.
Dang.
That was such a good comeback though.
first.
How is this still humanly possible?
You get a badge if you KO OSK in any game, so his presence
is probably lowering players.
Ah!
I did know about the badge, but I guess you're right that
maybe people are like, uh-huh, I want the badge.
Oh my gosh, Minto Room's so popular!
It's a party up in here, baby!
I mean, it's a...
It's like a... I mean, it's a Battle Royale party.
It's the bloodbath up in here.
Soap party!
With bath.
I mean with blood.
Whoa!
Committed to membership.
Thanks for inventing that trick.
Thanks, Paper Boss!
281.
That was my mess up, though.
It really was.
That was my mess up.
Got Girl Slayer!
Well, she couldn't slay.
One thing.
Couldn't slay.
In Tetriel.
So sad.
GD, everybody.
Practically a more beginner-friendly game, although when you
have a bunch of people from the highest ranks in the lobby,
beginner-friendly is relative.
Yeah, it makes sense.
No, I'm still having fun, though.
I have really good people coming.
I survived the worst exam of my life and I want to celebrate
law school!
Your ghost trick streams gave me life!
I'm so happy!
Congrats on finishing your exam!
Ugh.
Okay.
I got 20 seconds.
I saw you up in there, Amelia.
I totally saw you.
I was like, yo!
I saw- I got 49th.
It's fun to play Tetris with you again.
Yeah!
Alright.
It was huge fun.
Thank you!
Thanks.
I think people are leaving.
Maybe because OSK left.
Go you!
Penning message is just slash a message.
I am mint.
Oh!
cool that's what i wrote i mean i'm almost sweating i am
sweating
messing around with the game presets i think i um i think
things are pretty interesting in of itself especially with
my level you know
sorry for misleading you know a new godzilla minus one not
only on netflix but also on all streaming services.
Oh, let's go!
Now I can finally watch it.
Okie dokie!
Let's start the game.
I'm guessing do lobbies not get this big very often?
It's probably exciting for even the bigger players too
because they get to play with a lot of different people and
just a lot of people in general, you know.
So, you know.
It's fun for everybody, I'd say.
It's just a big old party room.
Whoa.
Oh, no, no, please, no.
God, please, no.
Please, please, God, no.
Please, I'm too slow on this.
Ah!
Please!
Please, God.
Please, Tetris, God.
John Tetris.
Ah!
There's no way I can recover from...
Oh!
I killed someone!
Sorry.
Hi, me!
Hi, KO'd somebody!
I'm a monster.
I'm a monster now.
No, no, please.
That doesn't make me a target, please.
That doesn't make me a target, please!
No, no, no, no, no.
Please, please.
Oh, no!
I'm throwing.
I'm throwing for real.
The pressure is too strong!
I'm too, I'm too good at the game now!
Karma for killing so many.
Monster Minto.
Dude came back at all, did you?
How does the blood taste mint?
Delicious.
You can now call me vamp.
Not because I'm a vampire.
How can you miss twice, Vinto?
I'm telling you, the pressure is too great.
I can't live with myself.
I'm not living at all, but I can't take this pressure of
knowing that the creator of the website is watching me,
potentially.
Oh, my goodness gracious.
Rabilia!
I believe in you.
That's my Toho Oshi right there.
Grape is back?
Oh no.
I'm not jinxing Ramelea.
These guys are so fast.
I know, right?
They're crazy good.
I'm gonna be there one day.
Thanks, Mid, for KOing me.
I'm going to cry.
You're welcome, Sir9!
I bet it was your honor.
Your pleasure.
Wandering Zero, welcome to Mambusha, thank you!
My name is playing in my head right now.
With the Castlevania music, it's kind of perfect.
Love the certified freak phantom glasses.
Thank you!
Is this real?
Chat, is this real?
When playing Tetris, the goal is in to win.
The goal is to be eliminated by men.
I think that will probably be my only elimination today.
I'm sorry to say.
They caused a natural...
They caused nature to respawn the thunder.
They had 23 combo!
Have you ever played any of the Castlevania games before?
I have!
I like them.
Hippie!
Welcome to membership, thank you!
Ah!
Zeus!
Zeus babus!
Zeus kabus!
Come on Zeus kabus!
The games are getting longer and longer, now we're stuck at
40 people.
The Zeus is loose!
Oh, 30 combo caused the thunder.
Have you seen the old Metal Gear Solid Flash video called
Crab Battle?
I have.
When I was playing MGS3, Oh!
A bunch of people kept recommending it to me, and so I...
Oh!
The Zeus got caboose!
Lord, welcome to Mavageup.co!
Tetris with my Oshi is scary, but fun this time.
It used to still...
You know, it used to be pretty intense back in the day too.
But I think...
I think we've reached new levels.
I think not only have people reach new heights,
but so have the lobbies.
I was practicing.
What's today in preparation for the stream?
And you did really well.
You've been doing really well.
Oh, they're dancing.
My bad for KOing you this round before this one.
Love you, she, by the way.
Oh, the round before this one.
No worries, Lallonie.
No worries.
It's all in the game.
Holy cow.
Sushi man took them out.
The sushi is raw.
Fresh from the sea.
Hey, boss, just quit my job.
Like cussing out my boss earlier.
I don't have much money.
Should I come back and pretend like nothing happened?
Yeah, I'm sure he'll just say it was a dream.
Also, you could go up to him and be like, chat.
Is this real?
He'll say no.
It's real.
There's hope to the most cracked on PC.
Just gaslight.
Say it never happened.
This person has no life and no game.
Oh!
I talk so much shit for someone that can't.
I can't.
I can't hold my own.
I don't think Sushi Man has won a game yet.
Aww.
Jeez.
Yay!
Oh my goodness.
That's so close.
I leveled up to level seven.
What was I?
215?
There I am.
Oh.
Rest in peace sushi man.
Sheesh.
I got 35 on that one.
Nice.
And Draco sticks with the tag gifted!
I achieved my mission of pushing mince ranking up by one
stop no all right thanks john ronaldo
min will win this one for sure yeah i'm i'm using tilt
controls
i even pinned my message
I'm using tilt controls!
Okay, the lobby's going down just a little bit, so maybe
this is our chance, you guys.
350 players.
What days will you be attending Anime Fest?
I think, like, every single day.
Not even lying.
They were like, can you attend, like, every day?
And I was like, um, uh, that's a lot of days.
Hey, hey.
Hey, we just started.
Not cool, not cool.
Not cool.
We just started.
Hey, all right, not cool.
Not cool, not cool.
Get out of here.
Um.
I'm holding my own.
This is a, this is a doggy dog.
Oh, no world out here, please.
Please, please.
Ah!
Oh!
Gosh, please!
This is... Oh gosh, it's such a doggy dog world!
No!
This is murder!
This is a murder!
Oh my gosh, hey guys!
Wait.
Thank you for the 50 gifted!
Holy cow!
Thank you!
I'm gonna go get some more water real quick though, guys.
I'll be right back.
I will be...
We are brave.
You guys can watch Nesulu.
It's a doggy dog world out there.
I pray you survive the exorcisms to come be well.
Thank you for the peek.
Thank you.
I'll be right back.
Yeah, bam.
I'm 100% getting worse each round.
No, it's not you!
I think people are getting better.
All the better people are coming into the lobby for real.
Okay, here we go.
I also got a slice of pizza.
It's cold.
Ah, no, no, it's here!
Blue Supertrap.
I discovered you with that drone.
Why are you so good at this?
I'm just a really talented...
Look, ma!
No hands!
There's doggy dog world out here.
That's what this song should be called, doggy dog world.
Doesn't it have some super doggy dog vibes?
Professional observer?
Sign me up for GDQ.
I'll observe all your games.
I feel more like a cool cat listening to this.
You're so right.
Sorry.
I'll react more once I've done my pizza.
How often does the guy play Tetris for people to get so
excited to try and get the badge?
I imagine he's also so good, you know?
Mint
won't read this.
Dill pickle and chicken on white sauce is the best pizza.
What?
Oh, he rarely joins public rooms.
I'm
gonna do an exam.
next week no you got this wipe their butts
chicken and white sauce sounds like you made like a weird
chicken alfredo
i ran a game at age agdq 2020 what'd you run
I guess I would kind of docks you though.
I think I'm okay with it.
Freaking ride looking phantom ride there.
I
can't even go.
As I say, I don't know if you can get out of that one buddy.
Oh pizza.
It's just a cheese pizza.
That's it.
I ran Battletoads Game Boy on Super Game Boy.
I thought Battletoads wasn't a real game.
So messy there, Theanna.
Oh, you got this, though.
I have no room to talk.
What the hell am I trying to give commentary for?
It's real?
Look, all game stuff in check if it's real.
It's actually real?
No way.
I was screwed over by the new lag-less monitors they wanted.
Oh.
I didn't want to make it difficult for them to set up a CRT.
That's okay, I'm sure it's not for like the records though,
it's for the charity.
Joy, thank you for the pink!
Thank you so much!
The Kingdom Hearts PC releases real!
You're right.
Cookie!
I don't think Blood can get out of this one.
Yeah, you're right, Kingdom Hearts is on Steam now.
That's crazy.
Crazy.
No!
830 lines sent.
A flood sent over a thousand...
This person sent 1200 lines!
1500 lines!
Sushi man is really fast.
Like stinking fast.
Whatever stream, Kingdom Hearts?
Probably not.
If I were to stream Kingdom Hearts...
I honestly only have any interest in the first two games.
So...
I don't think I would stream them, to be honest.
Good morning.
Good morning!
G-G-mentum.
Yeah, G-G-G-G.
Kingdom Hearts 2 is the best Kingdom Hearts for sure I agree
It's my favorite I remember I remember Like Killing off
Sephiroth Like trying that fight over and over and over
again Till I finally beat him I Yeah.
How is everyone so fast?
Um, go...
Wait.
Slap.
Go easy on me.
Please.
Go easy on me, please.
Here we go.
No.
Easy, please.
Easy.
Oh look, we're losing people!
Thank goodness.
I mean, oh no!
Oh no, my room is less popular!
Oh no!
Oh, this is so nice.
This is so nice.
What are they dropping the Tetrio soundtrack, huh?
This is so awesome.
Hey!
Whoa, why is it?
already so full!
Uh oh.
Oh, shoot.
I messed up.
Oh, I messed up.
There we go.
Ah!
Come on, man.
Oh, gosh.
I gotta go faster.
I gotta go.
Maybe.
Maybe we should let the good people have their own room,
right?
Oh, shoot.
Okay.
Get me out of here, please.
Oh, gosh.
I just...
Oh, okay.
And, uh...
My placement's all over the place, everybody!
Oh!
I think they left me alone.
Let's go!
Ah!
No, please.
Please!
Ow!
You know what?
I'm gonna go into Zen mode.
I'm practicing, you guys.
I'm getting...
I gotta get faster.
Okay.
Oh.
Practice speed.
Practice speed and placement.
Actually, it doesn't matter where you place.
It kind of matters where you place.
But it doesn't matter as long as you're fast about it.
You can get yourself out of anything.
As long as you're fast about it.
Why is the music so funky?
Oh, I almost said monkey because I was saying music and
funky.
But now I'm thinking about balloons.
Oh, what was I saying?
It doesn't matter.
It doesn't...
Faster.
faster faster faster oh see i can get myself out of that
easy peasy no worries it's got to be fast see look at that
oh boo boo i'll be boo and i'll bow yeah look at that see it
doesn't matter how how how bad you are as long as you're
fast about it oh it's okay everybody makes mistakes
Everybody has those days.
Oh, there we go.
Let's just slide that right in there, little pickle.
Everybody has these days.
Oh, I made another mistake.
Everybody makes mistakes.
Everybody has these days.
Maybe it does matter.
Maybe I had full on copium.
No.
Be bad quickly.
Got it, boss.
Sounds like straight up visual novel music.
Oh, it's okay.
I'm in a visual novel now.
And it's...
Somebody will die.
It probably was me.
I'm already dead.
This is it.
This is my...
This is my popular era.
This is my sexy arc!
Oh no, I died.
The music is so sad.
Oh no.
Oh, that's okay.
The ladies love me!
I think.
Uh-oh, how am I gonna get myself out of this pickle?
How am I gonna get myself out of this pickle?
With Longboy!
Longboy to the rescue!
Longboy!
See, now if nobody was attacking me, I'd totally be fine in
Tetris.
I am my own worst enemy.
Oh no, I died again.
Okay,
this is a good warm-up.
This is a good warm-up, right?
Yeah.
Oh!
Oh, I think I messed that up.
But that's fine.
L, L, L, Minto.
Sometimes when the orange and the mint blocks go next to
each other, they kind of look like brown.
You know?
We're gonna have- wait, we're gonna have labor party!
Go have fun!
You're going to a party, TFTI.
But also...
Oh, wait, what?
Why is the game attacking me?
What?
This is Zen mode!
Why am I getting attacked in Zen mode?
Where's the Zen?
What's going on?
Is it because people are angry that I haven't made a new
lobby?
New room?
Is that what's going on?
Is the game over?
I'm so confused!
Why am I getting stuck in Zen mode?
Why is my game haunted?
Oh, I messed up.
I am my own worst enemy, truly.
Hi, Raiders.
Hello.
I couldn't see the name.
I think it was Alien.
Thank you for the raid.
Oh, my God.
I'm getting attacked.
What is happening?
Guys, it's over for me.
Even Zen mode thinks I suck.
Even Zen mode is just like, just give up.
No!
I'm gonna have my Shonen anime arc.
Please, just let me prove it to you.
Saki, thanks for the vibe gifted.
Return to venue.
Oh, sorry.
Sorry.
We can start.
I was getting attacked.
I was getting attacked in Zen mode.
Wait,
was I actually- oh shoot, I need to pay attention.
I need to pay attention.
Fast.
I've trained for this.
Oh!
No!
Wait.
Let's get out of here.
Gosh, the soundtrack is so nostalgic though.
I remember this from when I used to play.
I used to...
Oh my gosh.
Uh...
Yeah!
Take that!
Oh...
Oh wait!
Uh...
Oh there we go.
I almost had it.
I'm just a little silly sometimes.
Don't worry about it guys.
Uh...
Oh.
No!
No please!
No, please!
It's not okay.
It's not everything is bad.
Everything is bad.
Oh!
I got KO'd by a weeb!
The soundtrack gives visual novels to all my games.
Guys, I was so zend out.
I wasn't even looking at you guys.
I wasn't looking at anything.
I was just in the zen.
I was just...
This is stinky.
Oh, Zen to Owl.
In this lobby, you're always KO right over the view.
Anyway, sorry about that.
Familiar is scary.
I think Sushi Man is scary.
Some of these people have, like, crape.
Oh, crape is back.
They have crazy...
Oh, OSK is still here.
They have crazy speed.
Say something really crazy for the clip.
Oh, wow!
But for a bit, how many games have you
won?
Of course!
I'm winning every game because I'm playing with you guys!
Obviously!
Not the tease, not the tease spin.
When they kind of like wobble it in there, they're just
like, do you want me to place it?
It's called the tease spin.
Don't make Vermilion mad.
This is Remilia's Scarlet Reel.
They would be better, but they're playing from Gensokyo, so
she's got some lag, you know?
Yeah, the bad thing.
Can change settings.
The ping.
Tetris Nubi!
Get out of here!
You wouldn't be top 40, then.
We can watch the king.
She didn't want to win it, seemed.
Yeah, that's okay.
Oh.
You got him next time.
Get him next time, Tiger.
That happened to me too.
Maybe I'm just as good.
Someone gets a badge!
Where do you see the badge at?
The feeling of being spooked.
Sorry.
Everybody I watch wins.
The curse of observation.
Kazania boy!
Oh, I was gonna say, how are you surviving then?
Yeah, I thought maybe I'll take off my glasses.
I might do better, you know?
La-da!
See, I told you I only watched the winners!
I told you!
He really hates Mondays.
That's why he's so happy it's Friday.
Duh!
162?
I guess it could be worse, right?
Where am I?
You were supposed to get out!
GG!
GG, GG, GG, GG.
GG's everybody.
Can you close yourself some multiple people to kill.
Alrighty.
Hmm.
And Phantom, if you're reading this.
I, I, I am.
I'm reading both chats.
Mini boy!
Thanks for two months.
GG's.
I always wonder why I added the...
Oh, it's cave badge.
Where do you see the badge?
Oh, maybe up in here?
Oh nice cool let's have a fun time mid mid armpits no let's
have a bad time can you sleep in I'm going to watch for a
bed with cat.
I'm going to watch in bed with cat.
Let's have a bad time.
Made Mint's room.
Get out of my room, you freaks.
You weirdos.
What are you doing in my room, huh?
Whoa, whoa, already?
Please.
Show some mercy.
Show some mercy, please.
Please, on this torso.
Oh, okay.
Got out of that for now.
Uh, uh, oh gosh.
Uh, uh, uh, okay.
Wait, wait, you know what, that works.
I could set up a team.
been there but I'm too nervous I'm too nervous I'm no don't
do this please there oh I got rid of it oh my gosh I got rid
of it I got rid of it oh oh I don't know if I can get rid of
this though oh oh shoot oh
Oh, oh, it's the same.
Everything is just bleak and sad.
Oh, no, no, no, wait, no, please.
Don't do this to me.
That was
too slow.
They one-shot in me.
How the heck?
Oh.
You got KO by Sushi-Man.
Look, that guy...
If that guy targets you, rest in...
Pick me!
That guy targets you, rest in pieces.
You're stacking pretty high, so no surprise.
I know.
I was trying to get it out.
I try to keep myself low, but I know you gotta stack high to
retaliate, you know?
But I'm not fast enough to return the hits.
Are you okay?
I'm okay.
I'm recovering from the sea virus.
But I'm negative now.
I can return to being a functioning member of society.
Wait, where'd Vic Niko?
Uh-oh.
Ray and Rex!
Metal Gear Rex!
We had Metal Gear Ray and Metal Gear Rex Right next to each
other
Hey there negative I
have goatee No I don't Oh a goatee Oh
jeez Anyway I thought I've just read it wrong.
I was like, that doesn't even make any sense.
How would I have that?
It's not something you have, I don't think.
I got KO'd by OSK.
It's time to put the freaky glasses back on.
Okay, mom.
Is that better?
Put those freaky glasses.
I'm not a freak!
My name is MidFantom, and when's not Freak Phantom?
I don't think anyone can match her, Freak.
My name is MidFantom.
Barely anybody even knows my name, hasn't it?
We can't change it.
It's FFF, Freaky Phantom Pride.
How to hold?
In this game, I'm pretty sure it's shift, right?
Shift is hold, right?
Shift or C?
Oh, it defaults to C.
Oh, I see, I see.
I see.
I see, I see.
What is that in your boy?
Congrats for first battle.
I have
a badge?
Wait, someone said congrats on their first badge.
Wait, is Remelia here too?
Zeus!
Pepe Island.
Sushi.
We got all the...
We have all the regulars up at the top.
Fast for my five business day replay.
Too real.
Malding in my chest.
Flood just flooded them!
Flood flooded them!
Holy moly!
I got 148.
Badge up!
Is this...
This is my badge?
I got a badge!
Yippee!
145?
Oh wait, I'm not so low.
You are...
One.
Freak Phantom!
Wait, Garlamo!
Cool.
G.
Oh, I can't type.
Get out of here.
Don't add me to your friend's list.
Now you can mold and tilt in Hydralink against all my
gamers.
GG.
You will never...
Wait.
You will never KO OSK.
Start the game.
I gotta rile them up a little bit, you know?
I don't think they're...
I don't think they're being sweaty enough here, you know?
I don't think...
We gotta put a little bit more competition into this.
Oh, oops.
Oh, shoot.
Hey, hey, hey!
I mean, yeah, that's what I wanted.
Oh!
Oh, it hurts.
Okay.
This is fine.
Probably.
Yeah!
That's fine!
Probably!
Oh, shoot.
I'm throwing.
Um...
I'm throwing for real.
No!
I'm gonna die.
This is where I died.
Freak Phantom!
I'm from Colombia!
Let's
go for two months!
Thank you.
I didn't even place 200.
So sad.
Couldn't match the freak.
Come back after two hours of overtime for a good stream.
Welcome!
O2!
Won't you trilingual maid?
I'm the seed.
Yes, yes, I like it.
Hello, how are you?
Very good, thank you.
I love you.
I'm Minto.
Nata, I like it.
Hello, Minto.
Wait.
Yeah,
yeah, yeah.
freak random.
Just wanted to say your streams always makes stressful days
better.
Thanks for being so freaking awesome.
We're freaking it!
Yeah!
We're freaking here!
This guy This guy KO'd me.
Everyone target the FIFO.
Target the FIFO.
FIFOFUM.
I smell your death on the line.
Ring ring, pick up the phone.
It's death calling.
Oh, yeah, yeah, there we go.
That didn't rhyme.
What if my dear friend Noko-tan was freaky?
I said, Freakano-ko-no-no-no-ko-no-ko-noko-tan-tan-tan.
Wow, what if?
That would be great.
Oh no, it's flood.
It's our winner.
It's the champion!
He's so fast, Flood is crazy.
I think though maybe the fastest is Sushi Man.
But he's fast, but he's messy, you know?
Oh, oh it's King.
The King!
Someone take this guy out!
You'll get a badge!
You'll get a badge, I'll gift it to you!
I'll personally give you a badge.
Oh!
Oh, almost save.
Oh, oh, no.
Oh, buddy.
My cronos.
Here's your badge.
There's your badge.
Freak Phantom.
Certified Freak.
You're a certified freak!
Oh,
see, the long boys are the same color, so it's perfect.
Certified freak.
Seven days a week.
Peepy Island.
My throat is actually really hurting today.
So I might just do a few...
Because I've been coughing a lot.
I might just do a few more games.
Tetris is very relaxing.
Yeah, that's why I feel like I need a shower after this.
Oh, oh, oh, Sushi Man!
Will Sushi Man finally get a win?
Oh my god, the recovery.
We're watching two gods go against each other.
This is insane.
Oh!
Sushi Man gets a win!
No way!
Sushi Man's crazy!
I almost made total 200.
GG's!
Get better soon, man.
Thank you!
I will, I will.
Tomorrow, I plan on playing...
If you thought this was a callback, wait until Till
tomorrow, I'm playing Doom 64!
But I'm actually playing Doom 64 tomorrow.
So, hola, hola!
No!
Um,
okay.
What's the next one?
Did
you see the prequel for the new?
Or the trailer?
It's a prequel.
Oh my goodness.
What a sweet sounding soundtrack.
Surely nothing bad can happen in this game.
If the soundtrack is so cute and sweet.
Right?
Right.
Oh,
I should probably not build up anymore.
Oh no.
This is why I shouldn't build up anymore.
Oh no, please.
Please long, boy, save me.
Long boy!
Long boy, won't you come down, Long boy!
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Thank you, Long boy.
You saved me.
Long boy!
Goodness.
That note.
What's that sound?
Oh, oh, shoot.
Oh.
Long boy!
Save me!
Long boy, I believe!
This is it!
Oh no!
Oh shoot!
Long boy!
I'll use you!
In my final moment!
In my... Oh shoot.
Long boy!
Sad anime scene music happening right now.
I know sad music.
I felt like a little village child in like a medieval, like,
anime who was about to die.
Wow!
Wow, did you see that the colors were so cool?
When the left bar is just all red.
Sad times.
Oh, did she read my comment?
Shut up!
I'll be okay.
I have some, um, some medicine that I can take.
But I ran out of, like, my cold.
medicine, because that's what I was taking before.
but I have some, like, throat stuff that I can take.
Oh, yeah.
We're learning the tragic backstory of a heroine.
Yeah.
She says, all I ever wanted to do is be loved.
All I wanted was a family that would love me.
But alas, I must fight in this cruel world.
In this war that I didn't ask for.
Just like Himmel the Hero.
Himmel the Hero.
That's a name I haven't heard in a long time.
Himmel the Hero would have given us long boy.
I think Himmel the Hero is long boy.
If it were just a little light blue.
Stop dancing.
Ooh.
Sounds like something out of Final Fantasy XVI.
He was a good friend.
Himmel the hero?
He wasn't just a friend.
He was a hero.
Get it right.
It's in his name.
He wasn't Himmel the friend.
He was Himmel the hero.
How dare you...
But disgrace his legacy like that.
Just don't friend zone him like that.
that I know I know free run did but she's still called him
by his title I'm
so excited for when more free run comes out I've just been
thinking about it like every day I'm just like when will we
get more free run please but we are getting what the set new
season of Oshinoko I'm kind of excited about that other days
I'm stole my mood ring
you the booster thank you i haven't watched dungeon this yet
i know a lot of people uh really like that show
usually i don't like watching shows about food because they
make me hungry like i watched food wars i didn't finish it
like i uh eventually stopped i don't remember what season i
i think Maybe I only watched the first season, but...
It's the best anime of the season.
Watch it while eating.
But my food never tastes so good, like it's theirs, you
know?
I did see though, like today it got confirmed a second
season or something, right?
Like it was very recent.
Or yesterday, or...
I
had them blue archive of the anime.
But I still play every day.
Dungeon Meshie is a trigger show?
No way.
Should I get...
Bring Giant Free Run instead of Giant Doki next time?
Me and Green.
Yes.
Actually, I also really want the Giant Free Run fleshy.
My hands need a Tetris break.
Oh, do it!
Oh!
Kronos!
They're the one who knocked out always capable of.
Level up!
Baby!
114.
Could be worse.
So far Mint has won every single game.
GG.
Maybe the next game, maybe...
LG.
Last game, maybe.
One more game.
We can talk a little bit and then I'm gonna head out.
Didn't you lose?
Nope.
I don't know what you're talking about.
LG.
Thank you, Flood, for always posting that.
Press X to doubt.
I pressed X, but nothing happened.
I did say I would do this after every round.
Appreciate you.
What happened?
What just happened?
Try pressing harder.
Weird.
F.
Top 100, baby!
I at least got top 100 in the very beginning.
And then all the good people came.
So you know what?
Alright.
LG!
Let's aim for...
Let's have no expectations.
B...
Beep, beep, beep.
Ooh.
I like this line.
I'm building.
My empire.
Maybe we can...
You know what?
I'm going to long boy in there.
Might have been a mistake.
It was not a mistake.
I got a strike first, you guys.
I'm the weakest link.
So I gotta strike first.
I gotta strike first.
I'm sorry everybody else.
I'm sorry!
I killed you, Sumi!
Oh my god, wait, no way.
I'm still playing.
I'm still in the game.
I'm sorry, Sumi!
I'm sorry!
Oh, shoot.
Uh-oh, uh-oh.
Uh, uh, this is it.
Save me long boy.
Long boy.
I got so...
Um...
Karma for so many...
Doremi is in here?
He's dangerous?
Oh...
Where at?
Oh!
I like...
When they just fall down.
So sad.
Thanks for killing me!
I'm sorry.
Mintos!
Dang, I didn't even get a top on...
I didn't even get it.
I don't think I even made it to 100.
I was so shocked.
And then I really came for my neck.
Glad I made it one match at least.
Let's see.
Let's go!
Oh, so baby.
I'm so sleepy.
My toes are better than my fingers.
You can make this out of this toes, I believe in you!
There we go.
Nice save.
Oh, oh, oh, nice save.
There you go!
Himmel the hero out to...
Himmel the long boy.
Nice save!
Your meds make you goofy?
I don't think so.
But I have to, since they're, um, their medicine is medicine
from Japan.
I have to take, it's like, you have to take three pills
three times a day.
It's so much.
And I only had, um, one left.
so I I think that's why I'm coughing so much because I have
no cough or suppressants anymore yeah nine a day it's insane
but a lot of Japanese medicine is like that maybe because
they put them in low doses you know they don't do like super
high doses for one pill so but it helped so much
You were the best Tetris player of all time, maybe ever.
Thank you.
Yeah, they do low dosages.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, Kronos!
Whoa!
Nice save.
Wow!
Professionals are scary, man.
But it's also so fun just watching someone be good at what
they do, you know?
I
wore the Mentara socks to the store today.
They're a lot more comfortable than I was expecting.
No way!
Oh my gosh, thank you for gifting me a month of Petraeus the
floor.
Thank you so much.
Chat is talking about Among Us and how Mint is gonna win.
Among Us.
Oh, don't read me, that's right.
Oh, here.
Were they in my...
Were they in the lobbies earlier?
I don't recognize the name.
They're a pretty famous Tetris player.
Oh, of course they're one of the best Tetris players in the
world.
Oh, it's an honor.
Holy cow.
I wonder if it's the real person.
What did I get?
151!
At least 150 are more to see to be a Pokemon.
Master is my destiny.
Oh my gosh, I'm view!
That's not so bad.
You know what?
I thought I was in, like, the 200s.
But actually, I'm in 151.
I feel blessed by Doremi's presence.
Lucky game!
Lucky...
I KO'd someone.
I got 151.
Almost to the halfway point of getting top 100.
So give me!
But even though there was only...
200 people.
That's fine, though.
There was only 200 people, but um, that's okay.
That's a okay.
Thanks for playing with us.
Toho, oh my gosh.
Toho.
Wait, what's her name?
Is that a clown piece?
How do you send that?
Oh, Yeah, how do you send clown peas?
Thanks for dropping by Intetrioman.
Thank you!
Clown peas!
How do you... how do I send clown...
Oh, clown peas.
Clown peas.
Clown.
Clown smug.
Oh.
Clown.
Smug.
Yippee!
Let's enter!
Clown smug.
Have fun Tetris.
Tetrio-ing.
Da da da da.
And we're out.
Give me one second, you guys.
We will go to the maid cafe.
It's been a while since we've been there, so...
It's been a minute.
Oh, where am I?
Yippee!
Let me change the music too.
Now I can check all my notifications.
Oh wait.
Wow, I have so many people who added me to their friends
list.
How do I...
Okay, close.
Um...
One...
One second.
Where is it?
Oh.
Wait.
One second.
Here.
Wait, where did it save it?
Oh, there.
Mm-hmm.
Ahem.
Where is Saber?
Under here?
No.
Huh?
Okay.
Maybe I did move it there.
I just forgot.
Ahem.
I did.
I'm so silly.
Wow.
Okay.
Thanks for playing with me, guys.
This is in Bluance 2 Day 6.
I wanted to play.
But I played earlier, too.
I played off-stream.
I got to, like, 167.
Whoa, clown fees!
Really?
Thank you.
watching these pros plays like watching somebody play
lunatic on toe you're so right my brain can't process it
thanks for all the games thank you yeah we really drew in
some crazy players you know we some really good people came
in we're like yeah I guess I'm gonna dominate in here that's
just what happens though that's just what happens I think
this is so fun I I hope you guys had fun too.
Periodically, we'll play some more Tetrio.
When I feel like getting beat up, you know.
When I feel like getting beat up, we can play more.
Let's have fun, yeah.
Super entertaining.
I'm glad if you watched.
I hope it was entertaining.
If you played, I hope you had fun.
Um, so yeah.
Do a private lobby for Membu sometime.
I don't know if that's possible i think it is possible
that's why they had the uh the what's the word the code at
the top um but i just did an open lobby just a public one so
it would be easier but next time now we can probably do like
a pub or a private one or something something like that
today i've learned how vast the ocean is but yeah it's
pretty vast
But yeah, I could do private lobby someday, sometime.
How would I do?
I guess I'll just show the thing on stream, right?
Is Tetrio usually this popular?
I don't know.
I only...
I only played it when I was teeny tiny.
If I got a super lobby, if I hit 100 people, I was like,
Yeah, wow!
I can't believe I hit 100 people!
so i remember i only hit like a super lobby a couple of
times very very rarely so this is a fun experience
used to be even smaller oh my gosh yeah when i first debuted
back in 2020 i was a teeny baby
But yeah, so it was fun.
It was fun seeing how crazy people can get.
And then we had some celebrities.
We had the creator of the site playing along with us.
That's so awesome.
So, yeah, it was really great.
They grow up so fast.
He wanted to know why the servers were on fire.
Sorry, OSK, if...
Did it cause you any trouble?
No, I'm sure.
I'm sure.
They have had more people in a lobby.
I'm positive of it.
And people, and they have the capacity to handle it.
I'm sure of it.
Just a little bit.
Tetria is so fun because lots of people can join.
It's really good.
I should get some rest though for my throat.
Tomorrow, I play Doom 64.
Sunday, I play it on streaming.
I don't know what yet.
Next week, Metal Gear, Saturday.
Do you know what time for a stream tomorrow?
4 p.m.
EST.
I might actually...
No, I might do 5 p.m.
EST.
5 p.m.
So a little...
Two hours earlier than today.
Any reason you're doing so many throwbacks?
No.
I just...
I played Doom 1 and 2.
and um I don't know I'm not quite ready for a Doom 3 yet so
I was like I'll play Doom 64 and uh
but I do I do want to play Doom 3 um I would like to play
original Doom 3 because it's because I want to play with
it's like it's you either have your flash the lights are off
and you either have your flashlight out or you have your gun
out.
So it's actually a horror game.
But I don't know.
I just felt like going back to Doom.
Just because.
I don't know.
Duke 3 is one of my favorites.
Hater's welcome.
And then maybe.
I think maybe because.
Because.
The new Doom trailer.
kind of inspire me i'll play up to uh like doom 2016 and
then the new doom once it when does it have a release date
what was it called doom uh oh yeah and then there's doom
eternal and wait or is that doom 2016 wait am i stupid
forget doom embrace doom no the dark age thank you Dark
Ages, release date.
Sometime in 2025.
Oh, so we have quite some time.
I'm wondering if Metal Gear is going to get delayed.
Because I haven't put up a...
A...
Release date.
I wonder if maybe it'll be delayed to like early.
next year.
I mean, someone put up a date for it.
You mean the GameStop one?
But they already clarified that was a...
A mistake.
My favorite about Doom is the music.
Yeah, right.
So awesome.
Need more time to perfect the pee-pee filter.
Yeah, I'm not rushing it, though.
I'm like, yeah.
I'll wait for however long.
I just can't wait to play it.
There's going to be so many more people getting it.
I mean, already with the Master Collection, so many more
people have been getting into Metal Gear.
I just hope that they can announce the volume too.
And I know it's not confirmed or it's probably a pipe dream,
but I really hope that they can find a way to get Metal Gear
Solid 4 on there.
I wonder who's making the music for Dark Ages.
I don't know.
Oh, I thought about playing Quake 2.
Well, not Quake 2, but like Quake as well.
Never played MGS 4 because no PS3.
I know, that's why I want...
There's so many people.
Like, that is the game that...
That...
It needs it the most.
I was really happy when...
the master collection came out though because I was like oh
my gosh finally more people can at least play the games um
like when they announced it I was like yes it can finally be
played more easily um so I was really happy about that uh
but to pirate 5 5
5 5 unrelated to anything but today NASA restored full
connection to Voyager 1 the thing is 46 years old and 24
billion kilometers away from earth I think it's pretty cool
what what
how is the battery lasted for so long haggaprobe that was
crazy
You weren't here, but for some reason I could hear you get
really excited when the MGS stuff was announced.
What, like the Delta trailer and stuff?
Yeah.
Space magic.
It uses nuclear decay for power.
Oh, wait, actually?
Oh, solar panels make sense, but...
What?
What has it...
What has it seen?
Oh, my gosh.
Google has, like, an interaction.
interactive diagram of the Voyager.
That's so cool.
Wow, I can zoom in.
What's the golden rock record?
Oh, carries a phonograph containing sounds and images that
would communicate details of life on Earth to
extraterrestrials.
What?
That's so cool.
If you ever play Ace Combat 7, would it be okay for me to
teach you how to post stall maneuver, aka Top Gun movie?
Yes!
I didn't watch Top Gun.
I didn't watch Top Gun on my last trip.
I was too sleepiest.
I eeped the whole time.
I didn't watch a single movie, which is extremely rare for
me.
Wow, generators powered by plutonium-238 radiation.
Oh, there it is.
Hmm.
How does it, how do they, how do they have the means of
communicating with it?
Radio dish antenna for communication with Earth.
signals how do they go so far imaging science I want to know
what it's seen what is it seeing right now so far away they
shouted it really loud hella good reception but if I go into
the mountains I get I get no reception what's up with this
huh how are we able to communicate with a satellite that is
20 34 billion kilometers away from Earth.
But if I go into a grocery store, I lose all connection.
Hey, now.
This is so messed up.
No mountains in space.
You're telling me that not even like the bajillion of
meteors that are in space is stopping, you know, are getting
in the way?
I doubt that.
For some reason, I doubt that.
No ceilings either.
No ceilings in space.
Just vast, vast emptiness.
Space is really empty.
Well, we should all just pack up and move there.
Let's all move to space.
This is me trying to get signal in some of the rooms that
are off guy.
That's true.
I used to think malls installed signal jammers to stop
people from having connections.
To instead pay for malls Wi-Fi.
Did your mall have Wi-Fi you had to pay for?
But no, I kind of believe that.
Because I feel like sometimes grocery stores do stuff like
that.
So that you can't compare prices and go buy it on Amazon.
I feel.
I feel like maybe they purposefully build themselves with
super concrete or something.
Hopefully I'm able to get them made in time for AX, but
Minto unit slash morale patches are in the works.
Shout out to Maple Slides.
What?
Maple are on a patch?
Wait, I want to see!
Do you have a preview that you can post to Twitter?
preview oh what do you mean oh oh oh oh
i'm checking my hashtag
chat summary the viewers are responding to the streamer's
remarks about a popular character named freak phantom The
majority of the conversation revolves around jokes related
to the streamer's mispronunciation of the character's name.
This is so messed up.
Summary.
This is a Twitch live stream chat where viewers are watching
a streamer play the video game Fall, guys.
Viewers are making comments about the streamer's gameplay,
the music, and the game itself.
fall guys oh yeah it was my first game i got 69 yes ask us
about freak phantom the chat is about a tetris 99 game where
mint quote-unquote dominates the other players ruthlessly
and quickly earning many reactions from viewers such as
admiration amusement and astonishment at the player's skill
yippee i'm going through the to a live tag right now the
chat is filled with excitement and joy as the streamer
affectionately referred to as the ghost lady interacts with
her viewers and expresses her love for them fans celebrate
the streamer's acknowledgement and share their positive
reactions expressing their happiness and gratitude for being
loved by her now everybody be great be be Be gratitude.
Express your gratitude as I show my love for you.
Be thankful that I am loving you.
Loving you is easy because you're beautiful.
I'm not going to say the next part because that's not what
we're going to do.
Thank you, Kami-sama.
Just posted on the tag.
Hi, Mint.
Oh my gosh.
Karlovo!
Thank you, Riloko.
Gratitude.
Can't hit the high note?
Not right now.
Oh.
La, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la,
la, la, la, la, la, la.
oh man you're the best ghost lady kiki i should go take my
medicine everybody go take your medicine okay i'm gonna go
i'm gonna go rest my throat and rest my brain from the butt
wiping that i got done today holy moly but i'll see you guys
tomorrow and we'll have a Grand old time Otsumita!
Otsumita, I'm just gonna go.
I'm gonna go.
Take my meds, yep.
Okie dokie.
Oh, my head kinda hurts.
Go lay down!
Have a good night.
We'll have fun this weekend, baby.
And yeah, get lots of rest.
After the week is over!
Yippee!
Yippee, yippee, yippee, yippee, yippee.
Yippee, yippee, yippee, yippee.
Yippee, yippee, yippee!
Yippee, yippee!
Awesome, yippee!
Bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye.
Thanks, Becky.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Bye-bye.